[Música]
eeuu es golpeado por varios eventos
climáticos mientras en california luchan
con las llamas las vecinas arizona y
nevada son golpeadas por temporales en
choque y las inundaciones provocadas por
las lluvias ya han dejado 26 personas
muertas
mujeres periodistas salvadoreñas
denuncian hostigamiento en su contra por
parte del presidente de allí porque él
es sus funcionarios y sus seguidores
prácticas que van desde el acoso en
línea hasta la persecución en las calles
hablamos con una de ellas
las costas de ecuador se deleitan con la
llegada de miles de ballenas jorobadas
los cetáceos vienen desde el sur del
continente para la procreación pero
durante los últimos años su viaje se ha
visto alterado por condiciones
climáticas y contaminación
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en eeuu una serie
de eventos meteorológicos afectan a
varios territorios del país un temporal
causó daños en arizona y nevada mientras
que la situación meteorológica en
kentucky continúa empeorando allí hasta
el momento se reportan 26 personas
fallecidas rafael pérez nos cuenta más
en el siguiente reporte
no escampa en los eeuu a las
inundaciones en kentucky se sumaron
fuertes temporales en los estados de
nevada y arizona las tormentas dejaron
importantes daños materiales según
testigos fueron de corta duración pero
con mucho poder de destrucción en este
test me di cuenta que este árbol y los
arbustos estaban en mi parabrisas
delantero y antes que pudiera reaccionar
comencé a escuchar virus rompiéndose
duró 10 segundos fueron unos diez
segundos prolongados
el panorama era devastador algunos se
salvaron de situaciones más complejas
estaba el teléfono y decía oye no lo voy
a lograr a tiempo lo siguiente que vi
fue que las estructuras se habían caído
sobre nosotros mientras tanto la
situación en kentucky empeora el número
de víctimas asciende a causa de las
inundaciones y se espera que en las
próximas semanas se encuentren más
cuerpos a medida que aumente el rango de
acción de los rescatistas tomaba el
nivel de devastación realmente no tiene
precedentes y nos llevará mucho tiempo
reconstruir pero nuestro compromiso mi
compromiso personal es que estaremos
aquí todos los días todas las semanas y
tantos años como sea necesario para
reconstruir en esta área este sábado se
confirmó la muerte de cuatro niños
pertenecientes a una misma familia el
servicio meteorológico nacional mantiene
en alerta al suroeste del estado según
ese organismo las lluvias continuarán
lunes y martes
seguimos allí en eeuu donde este fin de
semana se llevó a cabo una iniciativa
contra la circulación de armas en las
calles en texas un estado marcado por la
violencia armada se realizó una jornada
de canje de otros objetos por bonos de
hasta 200 dólares
más de tres kilómetros de autos en fila
esperan su turno para entregar armas a
cambio de tarjetas de regalo una
iniciativa del alcalde de houston texas
deshaciendo de las armas que podrían ser
robadas por un criminal así que cuando
lo mira de esa manera creo que es una
gran idea las armas son recibidas por
oficiales de policía para después
entregar a sus dueños casi 100.000
dólares en bonos las tarifas varían
según el tipo de armamento desde 200
dólares por un rifle automático hasta 50
por un arma que no funcione en el
momento de la entrega los uniformados se
verificaban en la procedencia del
artefacto
hasta 9 milímetros es una de las armas
que se han llevado hemos recogido
pistolas fantasma hemos recogido rifles
automáticas y por lo tanto el programa
está funcionando en orden la medida
afecta directamente el robo de armas que
luego pueden ser utilizadas en hechos
criminales aunque algunos no la ven
efectiva no dejaron de recibir su dinero
no estoy segura de que resuelva el
problema del crimen o incluso lo ayuda
en absoluto no estoy segura de que sea
un buen uso del dinero de los
contribuyentes nadie va a robar mi
pistola así que y la iniciativa se
desarrolla después de graves hechos de
violencia en este territorio uno de los
más sangrientos sucedió en la escuela de
vivaldi donde fueron asesinados 19 niños
y dos adultos
hablamos ahora del salvador donde
existen denuncias de que el gobierno de
najib uccle entre quienes se encuentran
funcionarios y hasta seguidores del
mandatario han emprendido una campaña de
acoso en contra de mujeres periodistas
actos que van desde mensajes en redes
sociales hasta vigilancia y seguimiento
previamente hablamos con mariana belloso
periodista salvadoreña en el exilio y
editora del medio digital feminista
alharaca y quien ha sido blanco de
hostigamiento ella nos comentó qué
consecuencias ha traído esta situación
para el periodismo
la primera cosa que puede usted es que
se nos cierran las puertas
ha habido colegas a las que han
despedido de sus trabajos que les han
cerrado sus espacios de noticias sus
espacios de entrevistas las fuentes no
quieren hablar con nosotras para evitar
sean atacadas también otras hemos tenido
que empezar a hacer periodismo desde
fuera del país con todas las limitantes
que esto representa la situación de los
medios en el salvador es bien complicada
el gobierno
contrató a una buena cantidad de los
periodistas que estaban en los medios
tradicionales y se los ha llevado a los
medios públicos que están destinados a
propaganda pero también mantiene
controlados y callados a otra cantidad
de medios más pequeños a través de pauta
gubernamental y seguimiento y acoso a
los medios que no se alinean con la
agenda del gobierno en brasil este
domingo se organizó la octava marcha de
mujeres negras que tuvo que suspenderse
dos años por la pandemia de coronavirus
en río de janeiro a las mujeres racial
izadas gritaron sus proclamas y
defendieron sus tradiciones exigiendo
más ayuda de las instituciones federales
para visibilizar las marta moya tiene
más detalles
las mujeres negras volvieron a las
calles en río de janeiro luego de un
parón de dos años obligado por la
pandemia de kobe 19 este domingo tuvo
lugar la octava marcha de mujeres negras
que exigen que el gobierno federal las
tenga en consideración y dejen de estar
marginalizadas que cuanto más prietas no
hay somos mayor sismo
cuanto más negras somos más racismo
sufrimos no pasa un solo día sin que una
mujer negra sufra racismo desde el
racismo más violento hasta el racismo
encubierto que duele igual el león como
a signo y creative judo hay la misma
forma durante la manifestación
las mujeres gritaron sus proclamas
vistieron sus ropas tradicionales y
bailaron al ritmo de su música
relacionada con la tradición africana en
el país suramericano allí también
pidieron proteger los procesos que las
protegen y las hacen sentir en comunidad
negra las vidas de los negros importan
esa frase es muy importante tenemos que
traer el woman is un proceso enfocado en
las condiciones y preocupaciones de las
mujeres negras para traer de vuelta
temas como los quilombos donde cada uno
cuida la otra si una sube tira de las
otras nadie suelta a nadie porque somos
la voz de las periferias somos las que
si podemos a poco más de dos meses de
las elecciones presidenciales el voto de
las mujeres racializada será esencial en
la pugna entre luiz ignácio lula dasilva
y jair bolsonaro según las últimas
encuestas el izquierdista ventaja al
actual mandatario por dos dígitos
especialmente entre las mujeres en las
costas de ecuador ha llegado miles de
ballenas jorobadas que cada verano
migran desde el sur del continente hacia
las aguas ecuatoriales para cortejar y
procrear lo que despierta el interés de
turistas que van a la ciudad ecuatoriana
de atacames para avistar a los cetáceos
samuel salgado nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
entre las olas ballenas jorobadas
aletean 10.000 de ellas han viajado
desde la antártida y la península de
magallanes hasta aquí las costas de la
ciudad de atacames en ecuador' nadaron
durante un mes subiendo por el pacifico
para llegar a las cálidas aguas
ecuatoriales y quizás encontrar el amor
entre el norte del perú y costa rica si
vemos un grupo grande que están en un
comportamiento activo como agresivo la
mayor parte de los individuos van a ser
machos esto se llama un grupo de cortejo
o grupo de competencia
con cantos que pueden oírse a decenas de
kilómetros los machos forman grupos para
cortejar a las hembras las ballenas se
comunican mediante sonidos porque su
visibilidad en el agua no es buena bajo
las olas cortejo y procreación
sobre ellas turistas animados que
esperan un avistamiento aproximadamente
tenemos alrededor de unos 3.000 a 4.000
visitas de turistas que ya vamos a hacer
la observación de ballenas pero la
migración de cetáceos esconde una
preocupante realidad el cambio climático
cada vez es más difícil para estos
animales realizar sus trayectos porque
las condiciones climáticas han alterado
los tiempos de caza también los desechos
de las pesquerías en las zonas
económicas exclusivas que se calculan en
11 mil millones de toneladas al año
representan una trampa mortal para las
ballenas y terminados de la capital
boliviana con una particular carrera de
karts sin motor unos 500 niños y sus
familiares se sumaron a la competencia
que se ha convertido en un evento
habitual para los locales desde 1950
los equipos se componen tradicionalmente
de padres empujando vehículos conducidos
por sus hijos los participantes pueden
escoger entre tres categorías carritos
de madera plástico o metal
con estas imágenes despedimos este
informativo en las 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]